[Music]
former Empire actor Jesse Smollett is
appealing his conviction for staging a
hate crime attack in 2019 and now the
man he allegedly hired to attack him are
telling their story smilett publicly
claimed that two white supremacists
assaulted him near his apartment in
Chicago the former actor described it as
a racist and homophobic attack causing
media driven outrage across the country
prosecutors accused smallett of
orchestrating the attack and then lying
to police about it fast forward December
of 2021 and smilett would be convicted
of five felony counts of disorderly
conduct last year he was sentenced to
150 days in the county jail but only
served six days pending his appeal now
in the midst of that appellate process
Brothers Bola and Ola osondario spoke
exclusively to Fox Nation about the case
and here's a snippet from that interview
where they actually recreate the
controversial attack
we started yelling the famous slurs he
wanted us to yell hey aren't you that
Empire
it's Mega country I mean he said what
did you say to me and then that's when I
threw the first punch at him
I held the blower because I didn't want
to hurt him of course so I made it look
real but I held it then we started
tussling moving moving around and then I
threw him to the ground he wanted it to
look like he fought back that was very
important for him because he said hey
don't just beat my make it look like I'm
fighting back and whatnot
is this the weirdest story of all time
Brian why are they speaking out now not
when all this first happened I think
because a bit of the circus is all done
and my other thought would be is yes
Jesse smallett staged this but with the
help of these two men they are just as
culpable as Jesse smallettis so in my
mind I'm thinking as a defense attorney
what's the statue of limitations uh in
the state that they're in it's 18 months
for a misdemeanor and three years for
most felonies so I think they're now
letting the cat out of the bag and
telling all the details because the
cases are behind them now the statute
limitation is far gone so no one's gonna
be able to use this interview and say
hey we didn't catch you for this crime
or this so you made it have a lie to us
during investigation now we can move
forward well Terry tell us about their
plea deal was it appropriate in this
case given the circumstances well Brian
hit it on the head it was not
appropriate as far as I'm concerned I
get you know putting them I guess on
probation but I do think it was a
serious crime and that not just the the
brothers but also Jesse smallett should
have more time two years probation and a
small fine for the brothers and 150 days
in jail and he only served six that's
not enough this was very serious it
affected the entire communities that he
was talking about the lgbtq community
the black community and it makes it far
more difficult when there is an actual
crime of this type a hate crime it makes
it far more difficult for those
individuals to bring their claims so I
think it was selfish it was unacceptable
and inexcusable and they should have
gotten far more time than they did and
now they're telling their side of the
story when we come back all eyes are
still on the Idaho College student
murders case even the alleged killer
Brian coburger is paying close attention
we're sharing new observations of
co-burger's Life Behind Bars
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are closely
following the Idaho College student
murders case including any new
developments in Brian coburger's journey
to trial now according to new claims
coburger seems to be doing the very same
thing from behind bars the 28 year old
is currently being held in the Lata
County jail and murder charges connected
to the stabbing deaths of the Idaho 4 in
November the site Daily Mail says that
it has been contacted by current and
former inmates of that facility and
these sources have revealed that
coburger has allegedly found God and
attends Mass every Sunday the inmates
also claim that co-burger has daytime
television access and frequently follows
his own case on the news in fact One
inmate labeled his behavior as bizarre
saying he quote watches himself all the
time another inmate allegedly described
coburger as expressionless and says that
he rarely speaks to other inmates and
despite these claims of odd behavior an
official told the Daily Mail that
coburger is well behaved and is also
getting V vegan accommodations in jail
his preliminary hearing is set for June
26th now Terry coburger was placed in a
private cell is that for his own
protection or the protection of others
well it's definitely for his own
protection he is being treated as though
he is some sort of Superstar he's
getting these vegan meals he gets
television he has his own cell and it
doesn't even seem as though he is in
solitary confinement which would be a
little bit different because that would
mean he'd have no contact with anyone he
is having contact they take him for
walks and he gets to watch television so
I definitely think it's for his
protection and you know the fact that
these other people are taunting him and
they are talking about you know his
crime and they calling him the b word so
I do think they're trying to protect him
but on the one hand that protection is
serving in his favor he's a very
egotistical person he is narcissist to a
certain point I mean as far as what the
people in jail are saying and so it
could very well be that he likes all of
this attention he likes the fact he's
getting this special treatment so you
know it's for his protection but I don't
think it's helping the rest of the
inmate population well Brian there's one
thing for a suspect to watch himself or
watch what the case is going on in the
news before they're captured right they
want to see you know where there's a
police going how do I avoid things is it
strange for somebody who's already been
arrested as a defendant locked up in
jail to follow his case from behind bars
I mean would you advise him to do that
if he was your client because listen to
these inmates right now yeah I'm not
worried about inmates Jesse it happens
all the time I mean think about it if
one of us sees on our phone that someone
tagged us on Instagram or Twitter or
social media why don't you pick up your
phone and say well what are people
saying about me take that then consider
it you don't get to go to work you don't
get to go to see your friends you don't
do all this stuff he's obsessed with
himself of course because that's all he
has I don't think it's a good thing or a
bad thing he's in jail awaiting for his
own trial and he's following the case
would I advise him to do this it depends
on what that person is doing with that
information and who they're speaking
with right now we're told that coburger
is pretty much a loner outside of jail
and now inside of jail as well if he's
not sharing information with the with
his jail mates or or people around that
I'm fine with that I actually want him
to follow the case so that when he hears
something in the news if I'm his defense
attorney he then comes back to me and
says Brian this is true this is not true
this is where you should investigate
more this is where he should not waste
your time that actually helps me but if
he's blabbing to his jail mates I don't
want him watching anything all right I
mean it's something that has been said
that they're even taking note and
thinking it's bizarre behavior Brian
Terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign